this video is about quite an obscure
molecule manganese pentacarbonyl
even I have to admit that it's not the
most important molecule but it has real
emotional meaning to me particularly
over the past few weeks because I heard
that Stephen Church my first PhD student
that I had here in Nottingham who worked
out the structure of manganese
pentacarbonyl for the first time ever I
heard that he had died and it's a really
very sad loss to me and made me think
again about manganese pentacarbonyl
so the molecule itself is got quite a
simple shape I've got a model here which
is one that Steve and I used when we
were working on this in the very early
1980s so you have a manganese at him in
the middle and five Co groups there's
just one atom here in the model but this
is carbon monoxide and the importance
about this molecule is that it has an
unpaired electron it has an odd number
of electrons so it's very reactive it
normally only exists if it's in solution
for a millionth of a second something
like that and normally two of these
joined together so instead of MN Co 5
you have mn 2 Co 10 so you mentioned two
of these joined together and the
compound
mn 2 Co 10 is quite stable you can see
I've got a bottle here so it's a yellow
compound and this compound has some
importance in as a catalyst in a number
of reactions so Steve's task in his PhD
was to work out the structure of this
molecule
I was his PhD supervisor I was the
person who was directing his work and
helping him do it and in those days we
were using quite an unusual technique to
stabilize these molecules so what we did
was to make the molecule manganese
pentacarbonyl in frozen argon beginning
with a more stable
molecule and shining light on it so that
sounds quite complicated look at this
picture and you'll understand it this is
a picture from the time that I
supervised Steve and you have to imagine
that this cake is a piece of solid argon
and the green cherries are stable
molecules that we have isolated in the
solid we then Sean ultraviolet light
onto these molecules and bits fell off
you can mention the currents as being
the bits and generated new molecules
like these red cherries and because of
the cherries are stuck there in the
solid and argon is unreactive they can't
go anywhere and they just sit there as
long as you keep it cold and you can
record the spectra and if you do clever
things with the spectra you can work out
the structure and that's what Steve did
as part of his PhD and we published a
paper in prestigious Journal of Journal
of American Chemical Society and here
you can see Steve's name as the lead
author the thing that excited Steve was
that I had done very similar experiments
when I'd been a PhD student 10 years
before Steve and I'd written my
conclusions and he showed that I got
them wrong and so this is Steve's PhD
thesis every student has to write a
thesis and here you can see the title of
his thesis low-temperature
photo chemistry of manganese and rhenium
he did both carbonyls by Stephen Peter
Church and it was finished in October
1982 and it's really typed by hand no
word process in things like this this
part of the picture is from my PhD
thesis you can see it says Polyakov 1972
and underneath steve has written here
bands that these things miss assigned
that's a posh way of saying got wrong by
Polyakov
he proved me wrong
and he was really excited so you can
imagine what I felt well I don't think
you can because I was really pleased to
because that's the way science works
when I did it I thought I'd got it right
but now Steve had got the right answer I
was really pleased science had advanced
I wasn't angry at all in fact one of the
really exciting things about being a
professor about supervising PhD students
is that you work with really intelligent
people like Steve and they think of
things that I don't so Steve worked out
of his PhD structure of manganese
pentacarbonyl by the time he'd finished
a group in Germany and the professor
Friedrich gravels had got some better
kit which was sensitive enough to detect
manganese pentacarbonyl in solution in
these few millionths of a second that it
exists and Steve went over there to
Germany and worked for a year and got
the spectra so he got spectra in
solution and then he went to America
where another group and Eric White's had
got even more sensitive equipment that
could make the molecule in the gas phase
and he recorded the spectra there so to
this day Steve's work on manganese
pentacarbonyl
is really the definitive work on this
molecule even though it was finished 30
years ago Steve was only 10 years
younger than me so almost like a younger
brother so we had really quite an
intense intellectual relationship and
unfortunately after he finished in
America somehow we lost touch and I
really hardly heard from him again until
I heard from his family about his sad
death and it's really sad for me that we
lost touch but there's one thing that I
really owe to Steve which nobody else
has given me when I was supervising
Steve quite often he didn't understand
something and would ask me to explain it
so I tried really hard to explain it to
him and at the end
he said he still didn't understand
because I'd explained it so badly so I'd
have to do it again I wasn't pleased
when he told me I was explaining things
badly but he made me do it again and
again till he understood it and that was
really valuable to me nobody else has
ever done that for me made me do things
again and again till I can explain them
and teach them properly and I think that
all of you benefit from what Steve has
done because he's enabled me to explain
things to you on YouTube in a way that I
never would have been able to do before
and I think we should all take a moment
to think about Steven church who was an
excellent scientist and sadly died so
young
you